you've been uh
a bit of an outspoken critic of strength
theory
maybe one question first to ask is what
is string theory
and uh
beyond that why is it
wrong
or rather the title of your blog says
not even wrong okay
well one interesting thing about the
current state of strength theory is that
i i think it i'd argue it's actually
very very difficult to at this point to
say what string theory means if people
say they're string theorists what they
mean and what they're doing is a
it's kind of hard it's hard to pin down
the meaning of the term but the but the
initial meaning i think goes back to um
there was kind of a
series of developments starting in 1984
in which people felt that they had found
a unified theory of
our so-called standard model of of all
the standard
well well-known kind of particle
interactions and gravity and it all fit
together in a quantum theory and that
you could do this in a very specific way
by
instead of thinking about
having a quantum theory of particles
moving around in space-time think about
a quantum theory of kind of
one-dimensional loops moving around in
space-time so-called strings
and so instead of one degree of freedom
these have an infinite number of degrees
of freedom it's a much more complicated
theory but you can imagine
okay we're going to quantize this theory
of loops moving around in space-time
and what they found is that they
is that you could make you could do this
and you could fairly relatively
straightforwardly make sense of
of such a quantum theory but only if
space and time together were 10
dimensional
and so then you had this problem again
the problem i referred to at the
beginning of okay now once you make that
move you've got to get rid of six
dimensions
and so the hope was that
you could get rid of the six dimensions
by making them very small and that
consistency of the theory would require
these that these six dimensions um
satisfy a very specific condition called
being a claudio manifold and that we
knew very very few examples of this
so what got a lot of people very excited
back in 84 85 was the hope that
you could just take this some 10
dimensional string theory and
find one of a limited number of possible
ways of
of getting rid of six dimensions by
making them small and then you would end
up with a an effective four dimensional
theory which looked like the real world
this was the hope so then
there's been a very long story about
what happened to that hope over the
years i mean
i i would argue and part of the point of
the book and its title was that um
you know that this this ultimately was a
failure that you ended up that this idea
just didn't um
there ended up being just too many ways
of doing this and you didn't know how to
do this consistently um it was kind of
not even wrong in the sense that you
couldn't even you never could pin it
down well enough to actually get a real
falsifiable prediction out of it that
would tell you it was wrong but it was
um
it was kind of in the in the realm of
ideas which initially looked good but
the more you look at them they just um
they don't work out the way the way you
want and they don't actually end up
carrying the power or the that you
originally had this vision of
and yes the the book title is not even
wrong your blog your excellent blog
title is not even wrong
okay but there is nevertheless been a
lot of excitement about string theory
through the decades as you mentioned
uh what are the different flavors of
ideas that came
uh
like they're branched out
you mentioned 10 dimensions you
mentioned
loops with infinite degrees of freedom
what what other interesting ideas to you
that kind of emerge from this world
well yeah i mean the problem in talking
about the whole subject and well partly
one reason i wrote the book
is that you know it
it gets very very complicated i mean
there's a huge amount
you know
a lot of people got very interested in
this a lot of people worked on it and
and in some sense i think what happened
is exactly because the idea didn't
really work
that this caused people to
you know instead of focusing on this one
idea and digging in and working on that
they just kind of
kept trying new things and so people i
think ended up wandering around in a
very very rich space of ideas about
mathematics and physics and discovering
you know all sorts of really interesting
things it's just the problem is there
tended to be an inverse relationship
between how interesting and beautiful
and fruitful this new
idea that they were trying to pursue was
and how much it looked like the real
world
so there's a lot of beautiful
mathematics came out of it
i think one of the most spectacular is
what the
physicist called two-dimensional
conformal field theory
and so these are basically
quantum field theories and kind of think
of it as one space and one time
dimension which
you know have just this huge amount of
symmetry and
a huge amount of structure which
and just some totally fantastic
mathematics behind it and um and again
and some of that mathematics is exactly
also what appears in the language
program so a lot of the um
first interaction between math and
physics around the language program has
been around these two-dimensional
conformal field theories
you